this is bryan dolby reporting from the
ftth council conference in munich i'm
talking to danny vossen of technicolor
danny you've just given an interesting
presentation about media content and
experience give us some of the
highlights well we're thinking Arab
we're talking about media consumption
that is changing in a way two things are
really important over there it's
becoming more and more social so people
start watching content and in the same
time there and interacting with peers
with family with friends about the
content so all the part of social
networking is being introduced here
which makes it a more individualistic
experience of the people another really
important thing is the second screen of
what screen as you might say experience
that people in the meantime get
interesting other data on the tablet
without disrupting the television show
show itself and they really can can work
with is also used for social social
networking but also for consuming other
types of content related to what's
happening on the main screen and this is
an interesting one to to see also what's
the impact on the bandwidth of this of
course yeah I think one of the things
that you did talk about was content
tagging which a lot of people may not
have heard of up until now tell us more
about what that is yes Beck related to
this second screen application or
experience if you are able to tech
content based on what is shown in the
scene special scenes actors brands even
based on voice excerpt of the of the
movie of all the content you can start
shooting or pushing content on the
second screen and this can be useful for
multiple purposes for advertising
purposes for promoting products that are
shown on the screen I don't know you see
something of coca-cola and the meantime
you get an advert of coca-cola on your
second screen app so this is really
interesting for the advertising industry
and this in a way fuels the over-the-top
experience because they are gaining
momentum and advertising money on this
to start experimenting with which is
quite heavily and this is quite a
problem isn't ever the operators because
the over the top people are getting the
revenue and the operators are paying for
the investment in your network to make
it possible
out there this is something that is seen
quite heavily and quite some operators
see over the top as a threat to them to
their own business because they have
IPTV the f VOD now other players use
their network to start streaming video
but they collect the revenues but they
have to invest in it and even more if
something goes wrong they're the first
to get the goals of not very satisfied
customers and this is I think a big
dilemma and in the end this will calling
to me my personal opinion will put some
pressure on the model as it is now and
therefore I think some new ways of
revenue sharing or other business models
or revenue models should should develop
itself and it's interesting to see where
it goes that nobody really knows even
the operators but time will tell I guess
okay well white and say thank you
welcome ftth connects the world when are
you getting connected ladies and
gentlemen welcome to Munich for the
ninth edition of the ftth conference
creating a brighter future